when I was very young like around 13
years old I used to travel to San Diego
and Los Angeles and I realized and I
noticed there that the air pollution was
horrendous at the time and I thought
well why should people live like this so
I learned about climate and air
pollution in more detail and then I just
dedicated my career so this is what I
want to do I want to understand and
solve large-scale problems of air
pollution and climate for the last 20
years I've been looking at both the
problems and the solutions but even the
last five years it's been more focus on
the solutions because we really need to
solve the problems at this point with
this course we'll learn how it's
possible to solve these major problems
that have not been solved before
including air pollution which kills
seven million people per year we'll
learn how to eliminate their pollution
entirely from the face of the earth we
will learn how to eliminate the
emissions associated with global warming
which will eventually result in
temperatures stabilizing and coming back
to pre-industrial time temperatures of
the earth and we will eliminate global
insecurities of energy resources which
arise due to the limited availability of
fossil fuels and their decreasing
availability over time so those who are
interested in transitioning those
companies those individuals and also
policymakers who want to pass laws to
try to effect a transition not only
cost-effectively but also equitably
would be interested in taking this
course so students in this course will
not only learn the details about what's
needed to go to 100% clean renewable
energy but they will also be given in
the information about what policies are
available to do this and and what's been
done so far you know the bottom line is
we need to combine word since we're
electrifying all energy sectors were
really a combining electricity heating
cooling industry transportation were
electrifying those sectors
we can use a combination of not only
renewable resources but electricity
storage heat storage cold storage some
hydrogen storage also what's called
demand response these techniques and
technologies are discussed in this
course and basically how to keep the
grid stable is something that hopefully
you'll be more confident about after
taking the class this skill is very
important today because there are many
jobs that require an understanding of a
clean renewable energy system there are
over 200 companies in the world
including 8 out of the 10 biggest
companies of the world that have
committed to 100% clean renewable energy
who is going to guide these companies
I'm optimistic we can solve these
problems and actually having changed my
own life by building a completely
renewable home with no gas just uses
electricity with heat pumps induction
cooktop stove electric cars and
generates more electricity than it uses
in the annual average I know that it's
possible not only do this on a local
scale but also on a large scale and this
is maybe passionate since I feel like I
understand the issues quite well now I
feel like the solutions are also at our
at hand and so it's very important to
provide that information to others to
help solve this large-scale problem that
affects humanity
[Music]